The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR ROBERT
FIELD: So last time we
talked about intermolecular
interactions.
Intermolecular.
It's complicated enough talking
about individual molecules,
what molecules can
do, but we could also
talk about interactions
between molecules,
and we can use perturbation
theory, and what we discover
is something universal about
all pairs of molecules.
Molecules which
don't have any reason
to interact with each other,
like being charged or even
having dipole moments, and we
discover that all molecules
are attracted to each other.
And we know the force law, we
know how everything scales,
and we also know that we
can look at molecules,
and say this molecule
is going to be
a good molecule for
intermolecular interactions
because either it has a lot
of low-lying transitions,
or they have very
strong transitions.
And so you can compare different
atoms or different molecules.
And one of the
important messages
is that really big
molecules are really sticky.
They want to attract
each other because they
have a lot of vibrations,
and each vibrational node
can act as a dipole in this
dipole-dipole interaction,
whether it's induced
dipole-induced dipole
or whatever.
So it's one of
these things where
something from one
half of your brain
is able to explain something
from the other half,
and that's really wonderful, and
we're always aiming for that.
Now, today we're talking
about photochemistry.
And this is an enormous topic.
And I would say that there are
vastly more physical chemists
and biophysical chemists
working on photochemistry
than on spectroscopy.
So what happens when a molecule
gets excited by a photon?
Does it just fluoresce or
does it do interesting stuff?
And there's a lot of really
beautiful semi-empirical theory
that enables you to estimate
the rates of everything
that a molecule can do, and the
uses for what these things do.
But in order to put
this in perspective,
I have to do a little bit of
review of the different kinds
of spectroscopy--
rotation, rotation-vibration,
rotation-vibration-electronic
in order to get
the energy scales
and to describe the actors in
this problem of photochemistry.
There's two sets
of notes, what I'm
going to be working from, which
is because I'm a small molecule
person, bottom-up,
and I'm trying
to take what I know
and I've taught you
about small molecules,
and extend it
to regions of
incredible complexity,
but using most of
the same concepts.
And Troy's notes,
which are top-down,
and he's basically
interested in photochemistry,
and condensed phases,
and big molecules.
And I'm afraid to go
to condensed phases
and big molecules, but
the two shall meet,
and many of the topics
will be understandable
with both approaches.
OK, so let's just
set the framework.
We have three kinds of
spectra, and the typical energy
associated with that
is one wave number.
And we have rotation-vibration,
and the typical energy scale
is 1,000 wave numbers.
And then there is the
rotation-vibration-electronic,
and that's, going to say
20,000 wave numbers and higher.
Now, this is peanuts compared to
the strength of molecular bonds
and interactions
between molecules,
but this is big news
because now the photon
that excites the molecule is
sort of acting like a reagent.
This energy, it goes
up as far as you want.
These energies are comparable to
the energies of chemical bonds,
and the electronically
excited molecules
can do chemistry that the
rotational or vibrationally
excited molecules can't do.
That's why it's so
interesting, and that's
why it's so complicated.
OK, now, what can an
excited molecule do?
Well, maybe I should ask you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Rearrange.
PROFESSOR ROBERT FIELD: OK, so
we can call it isomerization.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Fragmentation.
PROFESSOR ROBERT
FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Fragmentation.
PROFESSOR ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It can relax.
PROFESSOR ROBERT FIELD: By?
AUDIENCE: Emitting a photon.
PROFESSOR ROBERT FIELD:
Yes, fluorescence.
That's what we do.
There's lots of
things that can happen
and the kinds of
depends on what kind of
exaltation we've produced,
but the big photons
are going to produce
really complicated stuff.
Now, one framework we can talk
about is what is the rate of--
I can't imagine
what I wrote there.
So this is the
total rate, and it
can be composed of
the radiative decay
and the non-radiative decay.
Now, there's a size scale here.
Oh, I know what I wrote here.
That's measured.
So if you had a system and you
measured the exponential decay
of the population
in that system,
that's composed of the radiative
part and everything else,
and the radiative
part corresponds
to lifetimes no shorter
than 10 nanoseconds.
There is absolutely no way
that molecules or atoms can
fluoresce at a rate much
faster than one over 10
to the minus eight seconds,
and then there's other stuff.
And so when the other stuff,
the non-radiative decay
is fast compared to the
fastest the molecule
could decay by
emitting a photon,
then we're getting
into something
complicated and interesting.
When the molecule just
radiates a photon,
and this stuff is very
small, well, that's nice,
but it doesn't tell us
very much except what
is the radiative lifetime of
the particular excited state.
So there's various
kinds of de-excitation,
and there's collisional,
and there's--
well, we can call
it collision-free.
Now, remember, if there's no
collision, energy is conserved.
We have a Hamiltonian.
The expectation of the
Hamiltonian for an isolated
system is not time dependent.
So we have energy conservation,
yet in the absence of--
collisions are what
change the energy.
We remove energy
from the system.
We can have an incredibly
complicated range of processes
which are collision-free, and
these collision-free processes
have the signature of
the molecule all over it.
They are telling you something
about what the molecule thinks
it can do and does, whereas
the collisional stuff is
purely statistical.
So the collisional
processes, we can say--
we can estimate
how fast they are.
And first of all,
there is this number
that many physical chemists
carry in their head,
especially if we work
in the gas phase.
A collisional rate is on the
order of 10 megahertz per torr.
Now, I'm an old guy.
I do two torr instead
of bar or millibar,
but a torr and a millibar
are about the same thing.
And at atmospheric
pressure, that corresponds
to 10 gigahertz per atmosphere,
and so that means 10
to the minus 10 seconds.
So the collisional rates can be
competing with radiative rates
at atmospheric pressure.
Or in condensed phase,
they really can compete.
But this number, 10
megahertz per torr,
is a good number to carry
around for estimating
the frequency of collisions.
Now, there are different
kinds of collisions.
And one collision
with this sort of rate
is all it takes
to relax rotation,
and about 1,000 solutions are
required to relax vibration.
And now, it's very
hard to estimate
what it takes to relax
electronic excitation
because the electronic
excitation is so big,
there's so many different
things that can happen.
And so you could say, well,
if nothing really chemical
happened, it would take
about a million collisions
to relax electronic, but there
are so many other things.
I don't want to
put a number here
because this is really the
interesting and complicated
stuff.
OK.
In particular, suppose you
have an electronically excited
molecule, and it collides
with an unexcited molecule,
and you end up doing A plus
BCD or all sorts of things.
That's chemistry, right?
But this wouldn't happen
if this star wasn't there.
And there's a tremendous
complexity to chemistry.
That's why we have--
it's a BSD subject.
It's a major area of
science, and so we're
engaging with
chemistry when we start
talking about electronically
excited atoms,
and vibration and
rotation excitation
is largely irrelevant
to chemistry.
it's small potatoes.
You can see chemical effects
by rotation and vibrational
excitation, but that's
for the purists like me.
OK, now collision-free effects
are initially surprising.
We can have several, and
we've got some of those
from the initial
discussion, but I'm
going to just list them again.
We can have the molecule
breaks, and that could
be dissociation or ionization.
This is something
that all molecules
do if you excite them enough.
They either fall apart into
smaller molecules or ionize.
There's nothing
surprising there.
But then there's the
unexpected processes,
or at least they used
to be unexpected.
When I was a graduate
student, there
was still a lot of
confusion about what happens
in the absence of collisions.
And there are several
names for them.
IVR-- intramolecular
vibrational redistribution.
This process, which
you understand
from perturbation theory--
I talked about this
early in the semester.
This put closed to
the idea of vibration
or mode-specific chemistry
by putting an excitation
into a molecule-- a high
vibrational excitation
into a particular molecule,
activate a bond to chemistry.
IVR is always faster
than chemistry.
Or faster than collisions until
you get to the condensed phase.
IVR, that's one.
There was so much confusion
about IVR in the old days
that people didn't even
know what it meant.
It just meant I don't
understand what's going on.
But it is intramolecular
vibrational redistribution.
Then there's another process
called internal conversion,
and another process called
intersystem crossing.
So IVR is something that
happens in one electronic state,
internal conversion
involves relaxation
into high vibrational
levels of a lower
electronic state
of the same spin,
and intersystem
crossing is a relaxation
into a high vibrational levels
of another electronic state
with a different spin.
These are really two
sides of the same coin,
except that they depend on
different molecular properties,
and one can make
generalizations that
are different for IC and ISC.
So for a small molecule, we've
looked at this before, but--
we can excite directly
to an excited state,
and that's direct association
that comes like this,
and there's all sorts of
really neat things you can do,
where you can calculate
the Franck-Condon factors
or the vibrational intensities
for the different energies,
here, by knowing that you have--
you can calculate the wave
function for the continuum,
and you know you
have a big lobe here,
and as it gets
faster and faster,
the lobes get smaller, and
smaller, and closer, and closer
together.
And there's a thing called
the reflection principle
that describes the
rate of excitation
to a repulsive state.
And by looking at
the spectrum, you
can learn the slope and
position of this state.
OK, there's also suppose
you have a level here
of this excited state.
Well, that excited state has
access to this crossing point,
and so that can
free-disassociate.
So there's direct and
free-dissociation.
I like this stuff
too because if I
know the rate of
free-disassociation,
and what happens with
free disassociation
is you have a spectrum
where you measure
several vibrational
levels in this state,
and the vibrational
lifetimes of these states
are more or less the
same, and all of a sudden
the lifetime decreases.
Or all of a sudden the spectrum
goes from being sharp to broad.
Or the fluorescence decreases.
The intensity decreases
because the quantum yield
or the fluorescence
quantum yield
is one over tau radiated over
one over tau radiated plus one
over tau non-radiated.
And the pre-disassociation
rates can be much faster
than the radiative rates.
So this fluorescence
quantum yield goes down.
But the neat thing
is that you generally
know what the radiative
component of the decay is,
and so by measuring what
the actual fluorescence
quantum yield or the
decrease in intensity,
you learn something about
the non-radiative decay.
OK, I've also taught
you we can also ionize.
And we can have
direct ionization,
and it looks sort
of like this, or we
can have what's
called auto-ionization
where somehow, the molecule
is able to convert rotation
and vibration of the
core, and transfer it
into the electronic excitation,
and the electron is free.
So before you're actually
accessing directly,
an ionization continue, you
can have this other process.
These are things that I've
studied for my whole career,
and I know about it, and
I love to talk about them,
and we're not going
to talk about them.
OK, I also told you
about quantum beats.
So suppose we have a bright
state and a dark state.
In other words, we have
two states, one of which
has an allowed transition
with the ground state,
and one has a
forbidden transition
with the ground state.
But these are zero
order states, and they
can interact to make mixed
states because there's
some term in the Hamiltonian
connects the bright state
to the dark state.
So what you do with a
short excitation pulse
is you make some
coherent superposition
of these bright and dark
states, which at t equals
zero is the bright state,
and you get quantum beats,
and quantum beats
can look like this.
They start out phased
up, and they go down
like that, and so we have
modulation of the fluorescence.
Now, it doesn't have
to be 100% modulation.
It could be something
really small,
but it's always going
to be phased up if we're
looking at the bright state.
So we understand quantum beats.
Now, suppose instead of having
one bright state and one
dark state, light, dark, we have
a whole bunch of dark states.
Well, in that case, if you make
this coherent superposition,
you'll get many quantum
beats, but they'll all
have different frequencies, and
the quantum beats will dephase,
and it will look just like
the fluorescence decays
to zero faster than it's
supposed to be able to.
The ceiling on decay
rate of one over 10
to the minus eight
or 10 to the eight
per second, that can be violated
by mixing of the bright state
into the dark state.
So the ability of the molecule
to fluoresce goes away fast,
but the excitation
doesn't decay.
What you've done is you've mixed
a bright state, a decaying zero
order state, with
states that don't decay,
and the average
lifetime is very long,
but the experiment says the
lifetime is really short.
Because what's happening
is not that the population
is decaying, but
the ability to decay
has been spread among
many eigenstates,
and so none of them
are very good at it.
OK, so now you're
starting to get
the idea of how we can have
fast decay without collisions.
And all of these three
processes, which I've hidden,
IVR, internal conversion,
intersystem crossing,
are based on relaxation
of one kind of state
into many dark states.
So nothing is happening
without collisions.
Energy is conserved
without collisions,
but the signal
goes away, and it's
tempting to say that either
something magic has happened
and the molecule has
decayed, or you really
haven't gone to low
enough pressure,
and there really are collisions.
This was a very bitter
battle in the mid 1960s.
There was one faculty member
who taught the quantum mechanics
course, very much like the one
I've been teaching for years,
but he believed that
there was no such thing
as radiationless transitions.
It's always that the
fluorescence was quenched,
but he's wrong.
In the absence of
collision, what decays?
What decays is the
ability to fluoresce
or the ability to
do other things
like absorb another photon
to some other excited state.
You've produced the molecule
not just in one eigenstate,
but in a bunch of eigenstates,
and this bunch of eigenstates,
since the initial
preparation, is
the bright state
that's in that bunch,
and there's a couple among them.
What happens is
it's time dependent,
and the evolution of this
coherent superposition state
is the key.
Let's talk a little bit
about IVR some more.
When we have 3n minus
six vibrational modes,
there can be a very large
number of dark states.
States that couldn't be
excited by whatever method
you use to excite them, whether
it be an ultraviolet photon,
or a microwave--
anything.
You have a bright
state and a whole bunch
of states that you are not
supposed to be able to excite,
an anharmonic
interactions among them.
And we know some things.
So if we have a
cubic interaction,
where we have one normal mode.
So this would be a term
in the Hamiltonian.
And again, I lectured
on this before at a time
when it was probably
impossible to understand
the significance of this, but
you used perturbation theory
to say OK, what's happening when
you have an anharmonic coupling
term that couples
one mode to another?
And we know how do all
that sort of stuff.
And the selection rules
for that are delta vi
equals plus and
minus one, delta vj
minus two and zero.
We also know when we go
from the real coordinate
to the dimensionless coordinate,
we factor something out.
And for each power of Q,
that thing that we factor out
is a factor of 100 smaller.
We have cubic terms that
we have quartic terms,
and the quartic terms are a
factor of roughly 100 smaller,
but there's more of them.
And so there is an order
sorting thing, which
we can call delta capital
V, which is the sum from i
equals one to 3n minus six of
the absolute value of delta vi.
So if the total change in number
of vibrational quanta is three,
well, we have a cubic term.
If it's four, it's quartic
term, and the quartic term
has a coefficient, a
factor of 100, roughly,
smaller than the cubic one,
but there's more possibilities.
And so suppose we are going
to talk about benzene.
Well, it has 30 nodes.
And so we could imagine
delta v on the order o 30.
Well, it's 10 to the 60 smaller
than the delta v of three,
except that there's a
lot more possibilities.
So we have to think about how
big is the coupling matrix
element, and how many
states are being coupled?
And so there's a thing
that's really relevant
called the vibrational
density of states.
So at a particular
excitation energy,
you want to be able to know how
many vibrational states there
are because that, more
or less, tells you OK,
we're going to have some
kind of statistical coupling.
And if we know the density of
states and the average matrix
element, we could do a Fermi
golden rule of calculation,
and we can predict
what's going to happen.
Now, there are
ways of calculating
the density of states, which
are rigorous and beautiful,
but there's also a very
simple minded way of doing it,
which I'm going to present here.
So the vibrational
density of states.
This is one of the most
primitive, crude estimates
of density of states, and
I'll explain how it works,
but I'll explain it
by going even cruder.
And I also want to make
sure that I have it--
OK, this frequency
is in wave numbers,
and this is in wave numbers.
So we just changed
both quantities.
This is OK, and
this will give me
the number of states
per wave number.
OK, so let me do an
example for benzene.
We have 30 modes, and
here's a big assumption,
which is completely wrong, but
it leads to an underestimate.
Let us say that all of the
modes have the same frequency--
1000 wave numbers.
That's a typical number for
a vibrational frequency,
but benzene has a
lot of modes that
have much lower
frequencies, and only a few
that have higher
frequency, and so
this is going to be a
gross underestimate.
And now let's say we have the
vibrational energy divided
by Hc, and that that
is 10,000 wave number.
So we have 10,000 wave numbers
of vibrational excitation
in benzene, and we
have all the modes
having the same frequency.
So we need 10 quanta to make
10,000, and there's 30 choices.
So we have 30 to the 10.
So each quanta we pick,
we have 30 choices.
And we have to do 10 of them,
and so it's 30 to the 10,
but now we have 10 factorial.
We have to divide that by that
because the order of the 10
choices has to be corrected.
OK, and so this number is
1.6 times 10 to the eighth.
That's a big number.
I'm used to talking about
states one at a time,
and it's very rare that I have
two states within one wave
number, and here we
have 10 of the eight.
So let's go down in
energy a little bit.
Let's say instead of
10,000, let's go to 3,000.
And when we do the same
calculation for 3,000,
we get 4,500 states instead
of 100 million states.
So two messages.
One is the number of
states is really large,
and it goes up
really, really fast.
And this takes us into a
region of quantum mechanics
that we hadn't thought
about before because I'm
doing bottom-up, and
there is no place
in what I do for a million
states or even 100 states.
OK.
Now, let's talk about a
typical energy level diagram.
This is the ground state, This
is the excited triplet state,
which is almost always
the first excited state,
and then here is the
first excited sigma state.
And so for small
polyphonic molecules,
we have a very low
density of states here,
a somewhat higher density of
vibrationally excited levels
of the triplet here, and a
very high density of states
from the ground state.
So you normally look at
relatively low vibrational
levels, and there's nothing
much happening here,
and maybe there's
some perturbations
by a triplet state.
So we get local glitches
in the energy levels
and spectroscopic
properties, and the density
of high vibrational
level in a ground state
is so high that they might
as well not be there.
But now when we talk about these
collisional processes of bigger
molecules, we want to
use Fermi's golden rule,
and you've seen
Fermi's golden rule.
It tells you the rate
of various processes.
And so a rate, we
can call gamma.
Two pi over h bar times the
vibrational density of states
times H bright, dark squared.
So that's the
Fermi's golden rule
rewritten in terms to describe
radiationless processes.
It's directly related to
the first way we saw it.
And so we have the
vibrational density of states,
which as you go up
in excitation energy,
increases really rapidly.
You have the average
of the matrix
elements between the
coupled states, squared.
This is going to go
down because remember
when I talked about
vibrational matrix elements,
each additional
number in the change
in total vibrational quanta
causes this to go down
by roughly a factor of 100.
We have a big increase here,
and a big decrease here,
but this guy wins.
You can show that.
So now, we can draw sort
of a manifold of states.
So what's happening is the
density of triplet states
is much higher than the
density of singlet states.
And so if you were just
interested in IVR, well,
you'd look at that.
But this is a much
faster process,
and this is enormously
faster because the energy
gap between s1 and t1 is much
smaller than in the energy
gap between s1 and s0.
And so the s1-s0 interaction
is called internal conversion,
and that's usually way bigger
than the s1-t1 intersystem
crossing, but not always.
The intersystem crossing is
due to spin orbit interactions.
Spin orbit interactions are
predictable for each atom.
Extending what you
got in five-eleven-one
and five-eleven-two, you can
predict what the spin orbit
interaction is, and it's related
to the amplitude of the wave
function at the nucleus.
But anyway, what happens is
that carbon has a spin orbit
coupling constant
of 10 wave numbers,
and oxygen has one of
about 150 wave numbers.
And since we're talking about
squared matrix elements,
oxygen is 225 times more
effective than carbon.
And so if we have a couple of
oxygen atoms in the molecule--
or nitrogen atoms--
the spin orbit interactions
are much bigger,
and they can win over
internal conversion sometimes.
Depends on what
the energy gap is.
And now, molecules which have
strong electronic transitions
have chroma force.
It's not the whole molecule.
It's something about a
part of the molecule.
And if you have a
strong transition
at relatively low energy, there
is always oxygen or nitrogen.
And so the thing
that you're exciting
is going to have a fast
intersystem crossing rate
because it involves
oxygen and nitrogen.
But if you have just
a pure hydrocarbon,
intersystem crossing is
probably not so important,
but internal conversion
is going to win.
And for most
hydrocarbons, you can
have a nice, strong
absorption spectrum, but very
little fluorescence,
and that's mostly
because of internal conversion.
But the crucial thing is the
energy gap s1-t1, or s1-s0
controlling the relative
importance of ISC versus IC.
Now, you could also have
several different excited
states like s1 and
s2, and they could
be talking to each other
through a small gap
or to the ground state
by an even larger gap.
There's all sorts of stuff.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The internal
conversion process, you're
going from the first
singlet excited state
to the lowest level
singlet ground state.
Where does the energy
get redistributed to?
PROFESSOR ROBERT
FIELD: It gets excited
into a vibrational excited
level of the ground state,
but the energy
hasn't gone anywhere.
It's just now these guys
are not fluorescing,
and if there are
collisions, the collisions
can cause removal of
energy from the molecule.
And since the vibrational
energy gaps are really small,
collisions start to be
very effective in cooling.
But if you have a laser, and the
laser involves somehow exciting
the s1 state, and
the s1 state likes
to fluoresce to high
vibrational levels of the ground
state because of
Franck-Condon, so it has gain,
but there is often a t1
to t2 excitation, which
is in the region of the gain of
the laser, and it quenches it.
And so diolasers, which are
a fantastic way of generating
tunable radiation,
are always worried
about quenching by
triplets, and you
have to do something
clever to quench
the triplets to remove that.
So there's all sorts of stuff
about competing processes
that you can use it as insights.
OK, we don't have much more
time, and the most important
topic, I'm not going
to talk about at all.
So we can have isomerization,
and isomerization
takes many forms.
I've spent the last
30 years looking
at isomerization in a really
simple polyatomic called
acetylene.
And in the ground
state, you can isomerize
from high vibrational
levels of the ground state
to another isomer
called [? venility, ?]
and this is a really
interesting problem.
And in the excited state,
we have two conformers.
The trans-bent conformer
and the cis-bent
conformer, and they're
separated by a barrier,
and we can understand
both of those processes.
But the important thing is
if the molecule isomerizes,
its chemistry changes, and
so it will act differently.
Now, there's all sorts of
kinds of isomerizations.
This is a 1,2 hydrogen
shift, but there's also
intramolecular proton transfer.
There's torsions
where a structure--
one isomer or
conformer is locked
in by a lot of hydrogen
bonding, and the bigger
the molecule, the larger number
of isomerization structures
you have to consider, and
there's a lot of insight there.
So isomerization is
a very crucial thing
in the behavior of
large molecules.
The topic that I don't really
have time for is FRED--
fluorescence resonance
energy transfer.
Let's just draw a little
picture of a molecule doing
all sorts of neat things,
and another confirmation
of that molecule, and we
have donor and acceptor.
So at the opposite
ends of this thing,
clever chemists can
put things that--
and so this is a molecule which
has an electronically excited
state.
This fluoresces in the loop.
We excited, say,
in the UV, and it
fluoresces to the
red of the excitation
because that would happen.
In condensed phases,
you remove some energy,
and you fluoresce
from v equals zero.
And we have an acceptor
which absorbs in the blue,
and fluoresces in the red.
And the donor-acceptor
energy transfer
is related to one
over r to the six.
Doesn't that look familiar?
It's a dipole-dipole
interaction,
or an induced dipole-induced
dipole interaction.
It goes as one
over r to the six,
and so we might get a
lot of red fluorescence
from this molecule exciting
in the UV, and much less red
fluorescence or none because
we've increased the distance.
And this works in the range of
I think one to 10 nanometers.
Yeah.
So it's a fantastic ruler.
How much red
shifted fluorescence
do you get from donor to
acceptor energy transfer?
And it's a measure
of the distance.
And so you have a protein
and a denatured protein.
This distance
changes, and one can
use the way in which the
red fluorescence appears
as a measure of the structure.
So this is not like small
molecule spectroscopy
where you calculate moments
of inertia and vibrational
frequency.
This is really crude.
This has nothing to do
with quantum mechanics,
except it is, and it's just a
simple measurement of how far
two things are apart.
And there are all sorts of ways
of using this, including time
resolved waves,
where you actually
look at the rate at which
the one kind of fluorescence
goes away, and the other kind
of fluorescence comes in,
and many other things.
OK, so that's it for
me on photochemistry,
and you should read
Troy's notes because they
are much more
germane to what you
might encounter in real life.
But the bottom-up
approach, I think,
is useful too, especially
in the importance
of how the matrix elements
and the density of states
scale using simple ideas.
So I'll see you on Monday
and blow you away on Monday.